this is America and in American high
school if you're not hot you need
something else to get popular little
birdie told me you're having a critic
party I don't know what party you're
talking about talk about the stall of
Fame you're the only boy in school with
no tallies next to your name are you
saving yourself for marriage no are you
well
asexual because I have a pamphlet for
that he looks like Thor but like
ethnically ambiguous what I want to like
spongebob squarepants he changed a lot
got like really attractive really really
hot honey you're good-looking too he's
okay he's like a five six top the park
is a great place to learn to talk to
girls oh my god Wow it's crazy seeing
you guys again officer I don't
understand the misunderstanding
go ahead point is that I was saying we
weren't stalking them it just looked
exactly like we were wearing the
jeggings I caught you of course I would
man Jesus Christ
[Music]
what are you wearing clothes this is an
ABC party for anything but clothes you
think you can mess with people's car
it's just bizarre fly
oh I'm so glad I got into education
oh my gosh I'm so sorry about last night
I know right so much fun we should
totally hang out again are you gonna
promise
you
you